monumental farblos menschenfeindlich die
architektur des botulismus
es sind bauwerke die polarisieren
bausünden für die 1
doch eine wachsende zahl architektur
begeisterte auf der ganzen welt entdeckt
den brutal ist muss neu weil es
gegensätzlich und kontrovers ist
einerseits werden die bauwerke als
hässlich verstehen und sind wirklich
vielerorts sehr gewöhnungsbedürftig aber
wenn man dann ein bisschen hinter die
kulissen guckt und anfängt zu verstehen
warum die bauwerke so aussehen wie sie
aussehen dann eröffnet sich da so ein
ganzer architektonischer kosmos an ein
riesiges kreuzfahrtschiff erinnert dass
corbusier haus im westen berlins für den
architekturhistoriker und fotografen
wenig stalker ist es eines der
wichtigsten touristischen gebäude der
deutschen hauptstadt entworfen 1957 vom
französisch schweizerischen architekten
le corbusier 530 wohnungen auf 17 etagen
eine sogenannte wohn maschine namens
partie für den buddhismus denn er hat
den begriff beruht also und
unbehandelten beton erfunden und er hat
ihn bei dieser baureihe erfunden und
wenn man sich das gebäude anschaut ist
das zu einem riesen maschinen ungetüm
das aber gleichzeitig servo geblieben
ist
im inneren konnte le corbusier seine
pläne nicht verwirklichen nur eine
wohnung wurde nachträglich original wird
heu umgestaltet basierend auf der von
ihm entwickelten farbenlehre für le
corbusier waren farben genauso wichtig
wie grundriss und schnitt der schwede
henrik sweater und war sofort fasziniert
und kaufte die wohnung samt der meisten
möbel
wir werden die farben in dieser wohnung
nochmals ändern
niemals es ist wie ein kartenhaus es
kann ganz einfach in sich zusammenfallen
wenn man zu viel ändert unverändert seit
ende der 1970 er jahre ist auch das
botschaftsgebäude tschechiens in berlin
mitte ein gesamtkunstwerk die
architekten den waffen selbst lampen
tische und sessel
es beheimatet auch das tschechische
kulturinstitut in dessen ausstellungen
spielt das gebäude oft eine rolle denn
das interesse an dem architekturstil
wächst auch wenn er nicht von allen
geliebt wird
ich würde sagen diese
der besteht immer noch dass es entweder
geliebt oder ein bisschen gehasst wird
und natürlich ist brutal is muss jetzt
viel mehr in und ich versuche eben
architektur begeisterte in das haus zu
bohren und zu erzählen was das für ein
haus ist gerade veröffentlichte ein
britischer verlag sogar eine brutal
ismus stadtplan reihe felix torka
fotografierte und kuratierte die
berliner ausgabe zu finden sind hier
gebäude wie dieses hygieneinstitut vor
kurzem drohte der abriss nun ist es
denkmalgeschützt weil sie so markant
sind erleben die brut alles muss bauten
in sozialen netzwerken ein revival
ausgelöst auch durch kampagnen die
bauwerke wie das ehemalige berliner
tierversuchslabor vor dem abriss
schützen wollen
in den 60er jahren wurden damals würden
extrem viele bauwerke aus der
gründerzeit abgerissen bauwerke die wir
heute fantastisch finden und wo wir uns
die hände über dem kopf zusammenschlagen
was da alles für baukunst verloren ging
die waren damals gerade erst so um die
60 jahre alt genauso alt wie diese
bauwerke jetzt hier heute sind und wir
müssen uns überlegen ob wir nicht
dieselben fehler wiederholen
gleichzeitig kamen neue betonbauten
hinzu im stil des neo calis muss wie der
local block im berliner stadtteil
wedding
hier dominiert rohr beton das innen und
außen das mehrfach ausgezeichnete
atelier haus vereint arbeiten und wohnen
die rohbau ästhetik ist nicht nur
angesagt sie ermöglicht auch geringe
baukosten und hält so die mieten niedrig
in den letzten jahren es zu beobachten
dass es so neue freude an
handwerklichkeit diese ganzen kraft
bewegungen und das geht dann auch damit
einher dass die architektur wieder mehr
zum anfassen sein soll
drew tallis muss ein architekturstil der
vor mehr als 60 jahren entstanden ist
und bis heute spaltet und fasziniert
[Musik]